all right we're gonna go through all of
this very very slowly very precisely
there's a lot of ground to cover in the
last two minutes even breaking news I'll
get to in a second so tomorrow morning
we will finally get a chance to witness
one of the most important hearings in
the history of Supreme Court nominations
as I have said many many times the a 36
year old allegation made by Professor
Christine Ford against judge Cavanaugh
I've said from the beginning it should
be taken seriously and it has been by
Republicans by the President and a 10
a.m. in an open hearing they will lay it
all on the table and the US Senate they
will make an informed decision about
judge Cavanaugh remember their
constitutional role is advise and
consent of course context is very very
important 40 years of one's life is very
important
judge Kavanagh has been in the public
spotlight for all these decades and
because of his work he has literally
faced he has passed six deep background
FBI checks those that know Cavanaugh are
the best high school friends college
friends those that went to law school
girl friends colleagues fellow judges
clerks those people that have all worked
with impaired n't some of the girls he
coached in basketball and other sports
Democrats Republicans have all praised
Cavanaugh for his character his judgment
his friendship who he is throughout his
entire life he never until what 12 days
ago faced any allegation of any sexual
misconduct ever and judge Kavanagh has
been one of them has one of the most
extensive track records of any federal
judge he worked in one of the most
highest profile federal courts he's been
there for years and we also know that
Professor Ford and her groping
allegations against him have a lot of
issues we're going to go step by step
through every allegation tonight these
charges were made to congressional
Democrats well just a few weeks ago not
an independent law-enforcement agency
and by the way the claim dates back when
Ford and Cavanaugh were in high school
36 years ago and Ford cannot remember a
date a location of the alleged incident
she can't remember what happened before
after the incident the four witnesses
that Ford lists
to corroborate her claims all of them
deny what she is alleging and professor
Ford is represented by an attorney who
pointed out on this show is a left-wing
activist who once vowed to resist Donald
Trump at every level and whose
inconsistent on important issues
involving sexual harassment in the
workplace she didn't believe Paula Jones
obviously she defended al franken now
despite all of these warning signs it is
so important that Professor Ford and
Judge Cavanaugh speak under oath it's
important to take it seriously
now Republicans and the president they
have made every accommodation possible
when tonight Democrats are doing the
exact opposite they have already
convicted Judge Cavanaugh before even
hearing from him or professor Ford the
left so many of them rushing to judgment
on to other uncorroborated claims
against Cavanaugh allegations that are
so salacious they will literally tonight
make your head spin now the second claim
that came out in The New Yorker magazine
was so outrageous
so unsubstantiated then even Trump
hating New York Times refused to
officially report on it in this case a
woman named Debra Ramirez she alleged
that in the 1980s Cavanaugh might have
exposed himself to her at a drunken
college party
Ramirez herself she wasn't totally sure
if it was Cavanaugh if he was the
perpetrator according to her own words
her own account she became quote quickly
inebriated at the party she was quote
her own words foggy and slurring her
words and Ramirez even acknowledged that
she had significant memory gaps from
that evening those Ramirez listed as
witnesses in her case to the incident
they've all flatly denied her charge
including her own best friend
not a single person corroborating her
story not one and tonight just moments
ago we learned there's another accuser
now making an anonymous hearsay claim
about an incident that took place
between Kavanaugh and a woman in 1998
and this anonymous NBC news report
is obviously a report that I doubt NBC
News would ever make about Tom Brokaw or
Matt Lauer or Andy lack they wouldn't do
it about people that they work with or
have worked with over the years so the
question is how was judge Kavanagh now
supposed to defend himself from now an
anonymous accuser at the eleventh hour
which now brings us to the single most
sickening allegation that the left wants
you to believe as absolute fact it was
brought into the public domain but you
know him he's on what fake news CNN
every hour on the hour and if he's not
there he's over a conspiracy TV MSNBC
Michael avenatti the bombastic
untrustworthy fame-seeking attorney who
made it his life's mission to resist and
hate Donald Trump which is fine a
vanadis client in this case is a woman
named Julie sweat Nick and at this late
hour she is alleging that between 1981
and 1983 that she attended at least 10
parties where she claims that judge
Kavanaugh and his friend Mark judge
routinely drugged female partygoers that
this happened regularly almost on a
weekend basis and even in the summer in
an organized scheme to either give them
grain alcohol or give them drugs to gang
rape train rape these women she claims
to have witnessed this on many occasions
and also claims to have been the victim
of a gang rape where Cavanaugh was
present although she did stop short of
naming Cavanaugh as one of the alleged
rapists so she's saying that there were
ten parties this was supposed to be a
regular almost weekly practice where
gang rape took place and girls young
girls were drugged and raped and she
said nothing in 36 years nor did anybody
else who ever went to any of these
parties not a single person no specific
locations no specific dates were given
no names were given other than Mark
judge and judge Cavanaugh no other
witnesses listed
no one has corroborated these claims and
during the alleged time period sweat
Nick would have been enrolled in college
while Kavanagh
would have been a fifteen or sixteen
year old high school student she
described boys waiting in line to rape
drugged women and she says she went to
at least ten of these parties and many
more happen and nobody ever told the
teacher a law enforcement representative
apparent anybody everybody that was a
part of this all kept it secret
in a statement Kavanagh reacted to this
this is what he said this is ridiculous
and from the Twilight Zone I don't know
who this is and this never happened and
today just hours after these allegations
became public sixty-four high school
acquaintances and Friends of Judge
Cavanaugh they rushed to his defense in
a statement calling these claims quote
nonsense we never witnessed any behavior
that even approaches what is described
in this allegation it is reprehensible
in the extensive amount of time we
collectively is spent with Brett
Kavanaugh we do not recall having ever
met someone named Julie sweat Nick nor
did we ever observe Brett engaging in
any conduct resembling that described in
Miss sweat next so-called declaration
remember judge Kavanagh told her own
martha maccallum he was a virgin
throughout all of high school and most
of college can't believe we're
discussing this what we are is what he
said people generally in high school
think all of us have probably done
things we look back on in high school
and regret or cringe a bit but I know
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about an allegation of
sexual assault I've never sexually
assaulted anyone I did not have sexual
intercourse or anything close to sexual
intercourse in high school or for many
years thereafter and the girls from the
schools I went to and I
I'm saying that all through all these
years that are in question you were a
virgin that's correct
never had sexual intercourse with anyone
in high school Quinn's through what
years in college since we're probing
into your personal yes many years after
I'll leave it at that many years after
now today Senator Lindsey Graham he
tweeted out quote I have a difficult
time believing any person could continue
going - according to the affidavit 10
parties over a two-year period where
women were routinely gang-raped and not
reported and Graham continues quote why
would any reasonable person continue to
hang around people like this why would
any person continue to put their friends
and themselves in danger isn't there
some duty to warn others and also
breaking just moments before we came on
air new reports that a restraining order
was filed against Julie sweat neck by
her ex-boyfriend I was in 2001 her
boyfriend tonight telling the Politico
quote right after I broke up with her
she was threatening my family
threatening my wife threatening to do
harm to my baby at that time and then
she said in a telephone conversation
with Politico I know a lot about her
she's not credible at all
he said not at all look what the Wall
Street Journal is reporting just
literally minutes ago roughly a decade
ago Miss sweat Nick was involved in a
dispute with a former employer New York
Life Insurance Company over a sexual
harassment complaint that she filed
according to people familiar with the
matter representing her in the complaint
was the firm run by Deborah Katz the
lawyer currently representing dr. Ford
and the company ultimately reached the
financial settlement with Miss Sweat
neck according to people in the Wall
Street Journal
now despite everything we have now
showed you you have and this is where
we're in a crisis in this country many
in the left many in the media the
Democratic Party they have already
convicted judge Kavanaugh of what our
horrific life shattering claims and
we've got the evidence take a look this
is a monumental defining moment
week when you have someone like Cosby
going to prison and then in the same
breath having Kavanagh possibly going to
the highest court in the land to be
honest that is a very much a white male
Republican defense to say oh I was a
virgin I could not have possibly
sexually assaulted a woman part of this
backlash that we're seeing right now
comes from a culture of sexism and
paternalism in this country with the
patriarchy er are key in this country
has controlled everything has silenced
women generation after generation this
this this is the the patriarchy on full
display this is the patriarchy on full
display Brett Kavanaugh I never did
anything wrong I mean that that to me
was was you know it was just not was not
believable do we allow the the sexual
predator in chief the admitted
sexual predator in chief to place people
on the Supreme Court
he's picking the type of people that are
essentially like him and and and and
this whole thing needs a whole
investigation now it this should not go
forward while the left the media
Democrats all rush to judgment many
others rightfully are questioning why
someone with serious criminal claims
would utilize the services of the very
political the very anti Trump maybe
wanting to run for president sleazy
lawyer named Michael avenatti earlier
today the president had this to say
about him take a look if you look at
this lawyer that just came out he's a
lowlife he represented Democrats nobody
ever talks about that he's a Democrat
lawyer not a very good one but he's a
Democrat employer so it's a it's a
horrible con game I think the people are
finding it out I want everybody to think
about this because I believe Americans
are fair-minded certain about Republican
or Democrat tonight at all it's not
about conservative or liberal
even Michael avenatti Nancy Pelosi
Maxine Waters now the new faces of the
Democratic Party we have an election in
41 days avenatti
carrying up for a presidential run this
is now and this is what we've got to
think about this is now a party of no
due process no
of law no Constitution zero presumption
of innocence do you know it's in the
last 12 days I can't find a single
Democrat that is willing to defend the
principle a presumption of innocence and
due process by the way the party of Bill
Clinton and Keith Ellison so tonight
what we are seeing from avenatti and the
people on the left in this country sadly
I tell you this often they use this
tactic every two and four years
character assassination is the number
one tool than Democratic playbook
something the president called out
earlier today in a powerful press
conference how often do I say every two
four years they're going to call
Republicans racist how horrible is that
sexist misogynist xenophobic homophobic
Islamophobic Republicans want dirty air
and water and they want children to die
and they want to throw granny over the
cliff
we now have gotten used to it but to say
that about people every election season
to do this with every Supreme Court
nominee here's what the president said
they're actually con artists because
they know how quality this man is and
they've destroyed a man's reputation and
they want to destroy it even more and I
think people are going to see that in
the midterms what they've done to this
family what they've done to these
children these beautiful children of his
and what they've done to his wife and
they know it's a big fat con job and
they go into a room and I guarantee you
they laugh like hell at what they pulled
off on you and on the public they laugh
like hell now the president he knows the
shameful tactics of the left first hand
remember during the presidential
election remember the win the New York
Times I think was top fold they falsely
accused President Trump sexual
misconduct so-called bombshell story on
the only problem is the sources The
Times used denied the Trump ever acted
inappropriately now we know because we
interviewed the some of them a number of
them here's what the President had to
say about that earlier today I was
accused by I believe it was four women
you can check with Sean Hannity
you can check with Fox because they
covered it very strongly who got paid
excuse me excuse me I was accused by
four or five women who got paid a lot of
money to make up stories about me we
caught them and the mainstream media
refused to put it on television they
refused to even write about it we
actually followed up on this program
everyone else in the media ignoring and
just going along with the New York Times
put out there well I actually did some
reporting had the opportunity to
interview the women from The Times fake
news story here's what they said after
the Times made the accusation take a
look I have never seen him be anything
but a gentleman very gracious to women
very respectful of women and anybody
that tells me that I saw that is wrong
he was not that way to me he wasn't that
way to anybody I've met I met a lot of
women when I was around him he he
employs a lot of women he deals with a
lot of women and he respects them and
they respect him
I basically you know wouldn't give them
a story and now they came out with their
own version of it and took you know
something out of my book and just
totally twisted it and made it so
negative and I have nothing but positive
things to say about Donald Trump I don't
remember the retraction in the New York
Times either now the left's character
assassination strategy didn't start with
President Trump it is a time-tested
practice from the Democratic Party
remember what they did to Reagan's
nominee for the US Supreme Court Robert
Bork he was never confirmed because of
the fear mongering slander outright lies
from of all people a guy that left a
woman to die and told nobody after he
drove his car into a river and he walked
away and went home and went to bed
Chappaquiddick kennedy take a look
Robert Bork's America is a land of which
women would be forced into back-alley
abortions blacks would sit at segregated
lunch counters rogue police could break
down citizen's doors and midnight raids
and school children could not be taught
about evolution writers and artists
would be censored at the whim of
government and then a few years later of
course Democrats tried to drag Supreme
Court justice who has become one of the
finest justices in our generation
Clarence Thomas through the mud 1991
Senate Democrats pulled out his former
colleague Anita Hill making sexual
harassment allegations against him sound
familiar
this character assassination was so
vicious so horrible so nasty Justice
Thomas called it a high-tech lynching
take a look this is a circus it's a
national disgrace and from my standpoint
as a black American as far as I'm
concerned it is a high-tech lynching for
uppity blacks who in any way deign to
think for themselves to do for
themselves to have different ideas and
it is a message that unless you count to
an old order this is what will happen to
you you will be lynched destroyed
caricatured by a committee of the u.s.
US Senate rather than hung from a tree
well the circus the disgrace is back in
Washington and these tactics don't stop
at the Supreme Court nominees many also
try to destroy the character I know I
was in Atlanta at the time of the the
Olympic bombing Richard Jewell falsely
accused as being the lone bomber he fit
the profile because he lived with his
mother he was listening to my radio show
at the time and said I was with only one
that stood up for him and at least gave
him the presumption of innocence it
changed my life
they also smeared falsely accused
remember the Duke lacrosse team we
didn't rush to judgment on this show and
let's not forget what the left did in
Ferguson Darren Wilson was found
innocent in that case remember Baltimore
Freddie gray all the people saying he'd
be convicted Trayvon Martin George
Zimmerman how many times did the
president at the time Obama rushed the
judgment
the Cambridge police acted stupidly
during every big moment so many in the
left so many in the press rushed to
judgment for pure political gain there's
no presumption of innocence ever with
these people when it comes to politics
Harry Reid lies about
MIT Romney in 2012 said he hadn't paid
taxes in ten years then when asked about
it later after the election and Romney
lost he boasts about it he's proud of
his lie
this happens every election season one
of the biggest smear jobs that of all
comes from Christopher Steele's dirty
dossier a document bought and paid for
by Hillary Clinton and the DNC to lie to
you the American people to rig an
election in this country and then to
destroy a president after with absurd
untrue salacious claims like this
trump's perverted conduct in moscow
included hiring the presidential suite
at the Ritz Carlton Hotel where he knew
president and mrs. Obama had stayed on
one of their official trips to Russia
and defiling the bed where they had
slept by employing a number of
prostitutes to perform golden showers or
Jura nation a show in front of him well
during an interrogatory and Great
Britain
Christopher Steele under the threat of
perjury he said that dossier lets us raw
intelligence there's only a 50/50 chance
those lies were spread to you the
American people Hillary paid for it
Russian lies of all things yet the Left
pushed these unverified on corroborated
claims throughout the highest levels of
our government right into the gullible
media their arm that pushes their
propaganda and as you can see the left's
attempt to destroy the lives of people
with baseless claims it is a clear
obvious and now predictable pattern
these are real people unfortunately
these are real lives when you say that
someone's a racist sexist a homophobe
gang rapists real families Democrats
using all of them pawns in a political
game no due process no presumption of
innocence how would you feel if it was
you America tonight because this is the
modern Democratic Party they have now
defined themselves as a party of slander
smear character assassination a party of
besmirched men this is clearly who they
are because I can't find an Democrat now
saying they believe in the presumption
of innocence this now defines them
they only want power for themselves are
they talking about the economy about
security for the American people this is
why every fair-minded American has a
right to be skeptical tonight what
you're witnessing is one of the ugliest
smear campaigns in history if America
doesn't get this right there will be no
good people in this country that ever
want to serve their country for decades
to come
why would they they're not doing it for
the money Democrats are now the party of
no due process they're the party of no
presumption of innocence they're not the
party that believes in the Constitution
has one Democrat said presumption of
innocence I haven't heard them and you
want to know why because they all seem
to believe when politics and play when
power is in play that's what matters all
of this I hope you remember in 41 days